est ce que vous avez on va dire tiens
quel est votre rêve parce que lui son
rêve par exemple c'est d'aller à cannes
est ce que vous avez un rêve comme ça
que nous avons eue de faire sur les 48
prochaines heures
voilà vous seriez prochaine lors
s'étaient calmées sinon si vous pouvais
m'arranger de dos en plus comme ça avait
diffusé sur ce but je préfèrerais à
monaco la formule 1 monaco la formule 1
c'est fait non mais c'est vrai on
voulait que j'appelle tout de suite le
patron gérald brice viret suite après le
grand patron de canal+ jacques de mode à
une équipe de formule 1 ils m'ont dit
impossible monaco non qui a dit ça rend
des intellectuels et trois fois moins
donc j'appelle tout de suite j'appelle
toute financière serait le grand patron
que le relais nous dire vos rêves
je vais essayer de réaliser gérald
wiimote chéri comment ça va je suis en
émission l'action en direct frérot dis
moi mon bébé bon gérald mathieu de leur
moi un rêve c'est d'assister au grand
prix de monaco je sais que c'est sur ces
8 c'est le groupe canal est ce que tu
peux marc angers ça
merci mon général l'auteur benhaim quel
est votre aidera choix mais l'autre est
un truc et sympathique eh ben c'est rien
3 passes et le passe à mon pad à merci
évidemment continuer à travailler à vos
côtés autrement un abonnement canal+
aussi on veut deux abonnements qu'elle
apprécie voudrait qu'elle ait pu sera
sous peu faire et moi j'ai raté mon
chéri tu peux leur maître deux
abonnements canal
[Rires]
quoi qu'est ce qu'ils ne peuvent qu'être
appel demain et tu peux leur faire au
moins faire au moins 50% frais ont fait
leurs grandes consciences sur toute
l'année c'est pour moi c'est cadeau à
chaud pour travailler
canal alors on voit jean michel maire et
valérie bénaïm on s'occupe de von aura
la réponse demain merci challal je te
dérange plus gérable qu'est ce qu'on va
faire on va mettre en place un téléphone
rouge
oui oui ce serait de faire un aller
retour à las vegas et d'aller voir le
spectacle de david copperfield en
espérant et souffre doit avoir un
spectacle à las vegas jouer un petit peu
quelques jetons et puis ce fallait las
vegas
ouais bon bah ça tu te démerdes une
chimère d'elle je voudrais bien mais
fatwa barcelone ce week-end ouais mais
moi aussi je suis pas une agence de
voyage à jamal castaldi qui comptera
pour les prochaines ça ce samedi encore
j'appelle moi c'est bon vous la cotra
oui oui bon ça y est vous les couacs no
way oui ça y est je le rappelle est
sympa je les appelle giral
gérald ya benjamin castaldi qui voudra
contrat pour l'année prochaine est ce
que tu lui dis oui
[Applaudissements]
on a ou lite avec nous bonjour salut oui
oui est ce qu'on peut appeler monsieur
gérald pour réaliser mon rêve qui est
d'aller à cardiff pour la finale de la
ligue des champions
non mais ça c'est bien c'est bon c'est
bon quand c'est bon vous qui passez vous
prenez sur vous la france de réaliser
mon rêve
vous irez vous voulez qu'on appelle le
patron des sports de canal ah bah oui
c'est lui qui décide abbassi la tour et
tu te vois venir les chellois non j'ai
dit oui parce que j'avais pas envie de
d'épeler 4k encore gérald alors au tir
et comment ça va mon chéri tu as monaco
alors tu sais que je vais t'envoyer
matthieu delormeau pour le grand prix de
monaco
ah oui c'est vrai dit moi mon thierry
mon chéri je suis je suis à l'antenne
alors ne le patron des sports de canal
il me demande tous des rêves eya'a
gâteau proulx que tu connais qui
aimerait aller à la finale de la ligue
des champions à cardiff pour deux
personnes elle est une personne de son
choix
est ce que c'est possible ou pas donc
ces bâtisseurs cette affaire tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci mon dieu ne change rien
jean-luc alors pour les prochaines 48
heures je veux rien parce que je joue
mon spectacle à lille demain soir et
après demain
mais j'ai comme un rêve dites moi
j'aimerais que mathieu n'aille pas à
monaco
[Applaudissements]
jamais
jobin ou lorenzo gens lui non ils
arrêtent ils prononceront qui
choisissait non mais non c'est lui qui
choisira au coude mais c'était de
l'humour il appelle la rigole pas c'est
rebelle laissant le nom et votre
question je m'en fous je plaide patrick
schulmann après j'avais organisé mais
bon ça va mal j'appelle briser le
déranger au train de regarder la remise
des césar
amer il me répond plus on va essayer de
réaliser votre appli valeur mais je m'en
occupe